okay hi everyone yeah let's get started
so I guess today
uh we are going to talk about continue
to talk about in the implicit
regularization
um
so last time we have talked about
the implicit regularization
of initialization
and today
this is the last
lecture
actually last week we like in the last
two lectures we have talked about
implicit regularization of
neutralization and today we are going to
have on two parts so one part is we
continue with the implicit
regularization
um
and this is a better characterization in
certain cases as I would describe more
and another is that
um
we are going to talk about
classification problem
in all the past few examples we're
talking about a regression problem it
turns out that the classification
problem the the behavior is a little bit
different and
um
and you instead of like converting to
some minimum solution you converge to
Max margin solution which is in some
sense you know similar but not exactly
the same to the
um regression case
I guess uh with this lecture we are
going to conclude the discussion about
the implicit reposition of
initialization and the next lecture
we're going to talk about the
stochasticity and that will be the last
lecture about the implicit
representation
so okay so
So today we're gonna have so the first
part this is number one number two so
the first part we're going to talk about
a more precise
characterization
in a certain case about the implicit
probabilization effective initialization
you can see exactly how the
initialization influenced the recordizer
um and so and to
I have some preparation for today's
lecture we are going to talk about the
so-called gradient flow
I was trying to you know avoid this
notion in the past but I think the kind
of the Spirit uh has has shown up in the
past as well like so basically this is
screen designed with infinite testimony
um green descent with
infinite
testimony
right
so
um and the reason why this is useful is
because in certain cases
we have infinite test modeling rate you
can ignore some of the second order
effects from the learning rate and
um so this is just a mixed analysis much
simpler you don't have to say house
model anywhere is you don't have to deal
with the technology effect because the
second order effect is just literally
zero there's no technology effect and
the way to do this is that it's actually
also kind of a pretty clean formulation
of optimization even though it's
continuous time so so what you do is
they say you have a loss function let's
say LW is the loss function
so if you do green descent
then what you do is you say you take WT
plus one and now I'm using the
parenthesis for time because I'm going
to use that for the continuous time so
WT plus 1 is equal to WT minus ETA times
the gradient of the loss by time key
this is what we'll do with bringing this
set
and if you scale the time
by Beta what do I mean is that now
currently when you do green design every
time you increase the step counter by
one so before the time is T and now
times t plus one right so and now
suppose you don't do that you change the
time scale you say every every update I
only
Advance the time counter by ETA instead
by one so what I'm gonna get is that I
got W of t plus ETA is equals to WT
minus ETA
and these two process if effective are
the same it's just at the time the unit
of time change by a fact of ETA or one
one over ETA
um so and now if you scale the time then
you can take e to go to zero so
take each have to go to zero and then
this becomes a differential
um equation or kind of like a continuous
process so you can write this as WT plus
DT
is equals WT minus ETA gradient LWT
because depending on what kind of
comment you come from like you can also
write this as w t
dot right this is the derivative with
respect to I guess sorry I think here
you also replace ETA by DT this is how
you take
the the each had to go to zero and and
this is effective saying that the
gradient so that the the derivative of w
with respect to T which we denote by w
dot T is equals to minus gradient L at w
at time t
where w dot t
this is just a derivative
of w with respect to the time t
so and in some sense this allows us to
to ignore
the ETA Square term and it because if
the square here becomes DT squared which
is zero compared to DT so that's why
this is useful this will be useful
um
for us like this in some sense this is
mostly to simplify the equation like
like all the the technical meat in some
sense are the same it just makes the
analysis cleaner
and for the next two examples I've got
all on both in both of the examples I'm
going to use this gradient flow
formulation for green descent
um
okay so now let's talk about
um the the model we're going to discuss
so the model is a variant of the last
lecture
and there are some reasons for for
changing the model a little bit I'm
going to discuss that but it's not super
important
so for the model we're going to do is
that you have not some
quadratically
parametrized linear model in some sense
right so we have two parts let me write
it down so you have some Vector W plus
and you take this 0.2 minus W minus 0.2
transpose X where
we use this notation x0.2 this means x o
dot X and O the dot the the
this dot o uh is uh is the um this
actualized product
so so w Square minus W minus Square
transpose X and and w
and W minus these are both vectors
uh in Rd
and and you can write w as the
concatenation of W plus and W minus is
the parameter
so
and so so basically this is very similar
to what we did last time so last time
we had something like f beta of X which
is beta of the data transpose X
right so
um so basically now you have a negative
term in it instead of just positive and
the reason is there are two reasons so
so there are two benefits
compared to last time so they are not
super important but uh let me I know you
mentioned it the one thing is that it's
activator so so this model last time
can only
represent lead positively in the
combination
of facts and now
this fwx can represent any linear model
right because before if you take the
actualized product of Dublin debate and
beta is always positive or non-negative
so you can have only have a non-native
linear combination of the coordinates of
X and now it can have like a negative
coordinates
and another benefit is that
um
like now if you initialize
if initialize
uh W plus
zero I times zero two and to be equal to
W minus FM 0 to be the same thing
then
as you can see
fw0x is equals to zero and I guess for
every X just because the positive part
cancels with the negative part
and I guess you have seen this kind of
things before this is mostly for
convenience so
so this will make the
the analysis even more convenient
because initialization has a zero
functionality and we have you know kind
of like a
um use this for the ntk and
um
and and this will be useful on our
analysis and actually what we are going
to do today is that with this uh thing
we're going to see that if you change
initialization actually you're going to
get different regularization and you can
precisely characterize how does the
regularization depends on neutralization
and in one of the cases it will be done
you can in the other case it will be
similar to what we discussed in the last
time so
yeah maybe I should yeah mention that
so
Okay so
[Applause]
and
continue with the setup so the loss
function the L High W will be that's the
square loss
and we can and we we can consider
uh initialization as we discussed
or concentration W plus zero is equals W
minus zero so that's you get the zero
initialization as the functionality of
the initial model is zero and also we
for Simplicity we choose this to be
Alpha times all one vector and Alpha is
the uh the thing we're going to change
we're going to see that how does the
regularization implicit organization
effect depends on the scale of alpha so
when Alpha is small it gives you
something about if I speak it gives you
something else
and and this all one vector is kind of
like chosen as before
um in the previous lecture it's chosen
some words for convenience
um you can still do it with other
initialization it's just that the form
will be a little bit more complicated
um so and you can also have this
we can also have this Theta space right
so suppose Theta corresponds to w
um plus so let's say the W is defined to
be
W plus to the power 2 minus W minus 2 to
the power two this is the actual linear
function you compute uh uh the linear
function of w right so and we can Define
and and and we are interested in what
kind of like linear model we are
learning individually right so so let's
say w Infinity
let's define this to be the
the limit in time Infinity so the this
is how the green photo where the green
flow converts to and a large uh
Theta sub Alpha Infinity
and I think sometimes we just call this
uh this is the basically w
the course the model corresponding to W
Infinity
so so this is the the coefficient that
we care about right we care about when
you converge to Infinity what's the
corresponding of theta you get right so
uh what's the property of this this data
and sometimes we just call it
or simplistic
we just write say the alpha
and and omit the Infinity but this is
the the where we convert this to okay
and and for the sake of the Simplicity
of the lecture we assume everything kind
of have a limit so and so forth right so
all the regulatory conditions are
assumed to be met
okay and so and also just for to set up
some notation let this X
to be the data Matrix
and this is the Matrix and into D and
let's say y back is the label Matrix
label vector
okay so now here is the theorem that
characterized how does the characterized
implicit regularization
let me write it down on the interpret
so for only
Alpha
[Applause]
so
assume that
you convert to a feasible solution so
assume that
to a solution
that spread the data
so in a sense that X Theta Alpha is
equals to Y back right so this is
you know if this is satisfied it means
that we fill the data exactly and
um I'm using a purple color to for this
is because I don't feel like this is
necessarily have to be assumption you
can prove this actually uh the paper did
assume this uh in the theorem but I
don't think you have to
um do it and actually I just check check
we smoked a lot author two days ago
um and he also thinks that you don't
need it
um but but this is not formula stated in
the theorem so I assume uh but but I do
strongly believe that you can prove that
you can convert to such a feasible
solution
um you don't necessarily have to assume
it but anyway let's assume it
um so that we have we are consistent
with the paper
um by the way this is the paper by wood
I guess I'll probably add the link
would word
in 2020 and the title of the paper is
something that could reach and kernel
regime
I don't know I know I'm forgetting
what's the
rich and kernel regime over Prime
matches mode
so it's a pretty recent paper just it
just show up like two years ago
one year ago actually so
um and so suppose you okay so supposed
to have this then you
we know
Theta Alpha is not only a feasible
solution it's not only zero order
solution but also it's actually the
minimum solution
or minimum complex solution according to
the following complex dimension that is
the minimum complex solution
so you take Arc mean over Theta such
that X data is equals to Y so among all
the feasible Solutions you will try to
find
foreign
complexity where the complexity defined
by Q Alpha and what is Q Alpha
so Q Alpha is a function of alpha so the
complex measure does change as you
change Alpha and Q Alpha is equals to
Alpha Square Times the alpha Square
doesn't really matter because it's the
scalar when you do the argument uh times
sum
function of each of the coordinates
Q of theta
I
over Alpha squared
and what is this little Cube this little
Q is a one-dimensional function
where this little Q
is a function that Maps R to R
actually Maps R to our non-nactive I
think
uh and Q Z is equals to
something that I don't expect you to
interpret
but I think we're gonna look at
special cases which we can interpret
so this Arc such
I guess it's pronounced as science right
in the U.S or shine such
okay anyway accent
um
sign hyperbolic right so Z over two
I think UK is called Sean I don't know
why anyway uh yeah okay so
um all right so okay so the first order
bit is that even though you didn't
minimize this complex match in your
algorithm you only run green designs
somehow you find the minimum complexity
solution and the complexity is defined
by something like this
right so
um so now let's try to interpret this is
the abstract theorem but the important
thing is that in particular
when Alpha goes to Infinity so if you
have very large naturalization
then this complex match of Q Theta Alpha
this is something like
Theta
Theta I Alpha Square this is something
like Theta I Square
over Alpha to the fourth
so which means that the Q
Alpha Theta is something like
uh I guess one over Alpha Square Times
the two Norm of theta
Square
so basically if Alpha goes to Infinity
then in the so-called complex match the
Q Alpha
is the L2 Norm of theta
and
so and if Alpha goes to zero then what's
the complexity measure
so the complexity measure is oh what's
this regularization effect or complexity
measure this is Q Theta I over Alpha
Square
this is roughly
something like Theta I
absolute value over Alpha Square Times
log 1 over Alpha Square I don't expect
you to verify this limit because you
have to do some kind of like Taylor
expansion to see this but this is the
thing so then this means that a few of
us Theta is in some sense the one Norm
of theta
um I guess over Alpha Square Times log
well over Alpha square but the constant
doesn't really matter because
um it doesn't change the the order of
this
of the different data
um
[Music]
oh sorry
so so basically this is okay or in
summary so when in summary
but Alpha
goes to Infinity then this is minimum L2
Norm
solution
in a status space
of theta
um
and an L4 Norm
for for the w
right because Theta is the square of w
and when Alpha goes to zero this is
similar to what we discussed the last
lecture so you have the minimum L1 Norm
of theta which is the minimum L2 Norm
of the W's
so so this regime is what we have seen
in the last lecture and with a very
similar model right so
um
um but this characterized the whole
regime and there is so and and between
Alpha and zero you basically have
interpolation some kind of interpolation
between
L1 and L2
localization
so
so that's that's why this is more
precise than before right so you know
how does things you know interpret of
course you know it's kind of like for
any particular offer this the skill
function is a little bit complicated but
it's just the sum
kind of like some of like some power of
theta I in some sense
um but the power is kind of between one
so you can kind of think of it like that
but it's not exactly a power but it's
something like that
at this point
oh okay say it again
yes yes Alpha is the scale so this this
is the only thing that depends on Alpha
in the algorithm
so we say that the initialization is
Alpha times over vector
and this all one vector actually can
change it as well I think if you change
it to an arbitrary vector
uh for
for this regime for this case you
actually don't change anything
so for this element so for the other
element I think you change a little bit
because the L2 Norm becomes weighted by
the initialization
by the by the particular information if
it's not all one but if it's all one
vector the waiting is just all the same
for all coordinates if they are not or
one vector it's not open Vector then you
have a different weight
um yeah those can be found in the paper
I just for simply sell it and show the
exact rating
right and
so here are some iterations is about
this interpolation and in some sense
just to connect to what we have uh this
in some sense this is kind of like a
you can view this as a unification of
what we have discussed like in in the
past
few lectures when Alpha is small this is
small initialization
so
um
so this is basically similar to similar
to the previous case a similar intuition
to previous lecture
and but there is a small thing so it's
not note is that
um it's not exactly so this is only when
you have to learn when you go to a limit
right so you have the minimum out to
normal solution and then Alpha is not
when Alpha is not zero it's not exactly
minimum like the
the regularization effect is means the
regularization effect is not exactly
closest
uh solution to initialize
I think this uh the paper shows uh some
there's some tiny differences in some
sense so only when Alpha goes to zero
you can basically say this is the
closest solution to any strategy
um but but generally this is something
we have kind of discussed in the last
time
um and and when Alpha goes to Infinity
actually this is indeed this is the
anti-curity
so
[Music]
um
and why this is the NGK regime I'm going
to show you like you know this is kind
of similar to what we have discussed
before but let me just do it again so
why this is the anti-creaging so let's
look at the recall that in the ntk
regime we have this so-called two
parameter Sigma and the beta so beta
there was the smoothness of the
deluxiousness
of the of the gradient
and this is the condition number
right and we say that and recall that we
had this discussion that Sigma
beta over Sigma square meters
right so if this goes to zero then you
are in the ntk regime you can
approximate that quadratic and now let's
compute what Sigma beta is in this case
so the gradient with respect to the
neutralization X so w 0
let's
W 0 let's take this to be alpha or one
vector
W plus and W minus be both all and
Vector Alpha times all one vector
and
um
and we can compute the gradient and in
transition
X right so there are two set of
parameters right so the gradient for the
W plus I think you can if you compute is
something like this
an agreement for the W minus is the
students
oh sorry this is an element white
product
you can do this easily just by 10 rule
for every dimension
and
this is just the
equals to I guess there's a two Factor
two here which I
oftentimes probably look out and this is
too Alpha
because these two are just all one
vector so this is two alpha x minus X
sometimes
right so and now you can see that
Sigma and beta
both
linearly
dependent Alpha
right so what is Sigma Sigma is the
condition number of this of Sigma is the
condition number of the
the gradient Matrix right the feature
Matrix that consist of the gradient for
every little point and the condition
number scale linearly
in Alpha right and beta is deliciousness
which also scales linearly in Alpha
that's because Alpha is Multiplied in
front of the gradient just so so both of
these scales linearly so that's why beta
over Sigma Square will converge to zero
as Alpha goes to Infinity because
below you have degree 2 uh dependency on
Alpha and in the in the denominator you
have degree in the numerator you have
degree
like you have a linear dependency on
Alpha so that's why uh this this whole
thing you know goes to zero as Alpha
goes to Infinity
so and also like when Alpha goes to
Infinity
this is the ntk regime
for the for the trivial feature because
now
the XR V of X is this this thing
this feature map is really just
literally this right
this is just a literally the trio
feature because the only thing you did
is that you flipped the X which doesn't
really make any difference essentially
so so
um so basically you got the minimum Norm
solution so you got
so so if you believe in the ntk
perspective you should get the minimum
Norm solution so the ntk perspective
will also tell you that you get minimum
Norm solution
um
uh
like according to the features right you
know Norm solution
minimum L2 Norm solution
using
the feature
basically x minus X
and x minus X is in terms of a feature
that is not very different from X itself
so so basically you just get essentially
the minimum L2 Norm solution for the
linear model
so so that's the same as we um
we discussed like the same conclusion as
we discussed about
any questions so far
foreign
I think this is just because we'll do
the kernel method so
so when you use kernel method so ntk
tells you that you are doing kernel
method with certain feature
so ntk means kernel method
and the feature just turns out to be
this chillio feature and and kernel
message with the feature it just gave
you the minimum Solution that's that's
the that's where the kernel method does
so because what kernel Master does is
that you
like
that's that's just what the chronometer
do like a
um when you don't have enough data when
you when your kernel like when you
feature Dimension it's bigger than the
number of examples
uh in a kernel method you are learning
the minimum solution
uh for the features
because otherwise you know you have to
define something right so the kernel
method everything is L2 so you are
minimizing L2 Norm that's implicitly in
the in the kernel method
that doesn't depend on your transition
because it's a convex problem
uh
yeah
uh and yeah and you use a particular
algorithm when you do the kernel method
that my algorithm give you the minimum
solution
foreign
feel that better
you know
yep so so I guess so
um in some sense repeating the question
and also answering it so when Arthur
Goes To infinity
um
so yes so your
um your problem will be very your post
in some sense like the optimization
landscape will be very bad just because
your function will be not very smooth
um so and and this part is hidden here
because you are using gradient flow so
you can so you are using infinite
testable smaller than Rick so that's why
it's hidden under the it's left and the
bug and in practically
um you don't
uh you also don't necessarily want to
use the large and rate for one reason is
the optimization and the other reason is
that maybe the L2 Norm solution is also
not good right so like you also want you
have L1 representation at least for this
particular setting right so that's
another reason why you don't want to use
very large learning rate
um so uh sorry we're very large
initialization
um and another thing is that in practice
people sometimes do use like this is
about the empirical setup when like
sometimes people do use large
initialization
but people don't use infinitesimal
smaller Direct
so so then you still cannot get into the
antichrology
but that's a good thing because you
don't want to go to the NCAA regime so
so that's that's why at the beginning
some people have confusions because at
the very the very first paper by um this
ntk paper I think they are claiming that
in transition scheme they are studying
studying is actually what people do in
practice and that's kind of true that's
kind of it's very close to the the
timing uh the Communist neutralization
or the the Xavier initialization so
um in terms of the scale but because
they are using very very small learning
rate so it's actually not really the
theory the theoretical setup requires
very very small learning rate but
empirical you don't use those smaller
rates and also the theoretical setup
doesn't have the stochasticity so all of
this together it makes the theoretical
setup different from the empirical
setting
and and and and and that's a good thing
because the theoretical setup says that
you don't really do anything super
different from kernels
okay so now let's discuss the proof of
this theorem so um
I don't have a like there is a little
bit kind of like this this proof is kind
of interesting in the sense that it's
it's the proof is similar
to the actual the linear regression
model
similar to the
the linear regression proof
but not similar
not similar
to what we discussed last time
now similar to the last lecture but you
would probably guess this is similar to
loss actually because the last lecture
has almost the same model as this one
and it's only doing a sub case of this
right when Alpha goes to zero
but it turns out that the proof is very
similar to the linear regression one and
you have this this two steps the first
step is that you find the environment
foreign
by the
by the algorithm by the optimizer
and recall that this environment was
was that Theta is in a span
of x i
right for any regression
this was like a probably like two or
three lectures ago when we analyzed the
implicit
to accreditation fact of initialization
for linear regression we say that
because Universe at zero and you use
green in Sun you're always in the span
of the data
and and here we're going to find a
different environments which is more
complicated and it's even harder to
express but if we're going to find an
environment and then you use the
environment
so
so step two
uh like like a kind of like in some
sense characterized I guess credit cards
is a very weak term but characterize the
solution using environments you can
sometimes use the environments as
additional
um
additional information
right to to pin down which solution you
converts to right in some sense the
difficulty is that if you
without any additional thing you just
know that you convert to a zero hour
solution you don't know which one you
converts to and the environment tells
you that which one you converge to and
the environment depends on Alpha
so
um
and there's nothing about nothing about
population versus
population
versus empirical like everything is
empirical here
right I don't even I didn't even Define
where the data come from right I I only
tell you that this is the minimum
solution such that the empirical error
is zero I don't have to care about
population at all
so
um yeah how does this kind of techniques
compare with the techniques we discussed
the last time where you used the fact
that the data the empirical laws
concentrates
around the population loss in certain
regions and you somehow do some kind of
like control of the Dynamics you know I
don't know how it's kind of hard to
compare like
these are two different approaches
there's some
good thing about this kind of approach
because this doesn't require population
that sounds a good good thing but the
but the bad things about this approach
seems to be that it's very hard to find
an environments for harder
for other models or like for for more
complex models the environments you will
see the environment is a little bit of
magical somehow
um but that's that you know for more
complex models even the previous
approach the approach we discussed last
time wouldn't work either so so it's
hard to say uh anyway so let's proceed
to see how does the proof work
so
um we need to alert my notation to
somehow simplify our expectation so
let's say let's X tilde to be the
extended data Matrix
so you expanded Matrix to
this is to deal with the
the
this is
your concatenate X and minus X so that
you get by 2D Matrix and sometimes this
is just to try to write everything in
Matrix notation so that you don't have
to have the minus link so I so we will
take WT to be the concatenation of W
plus t
and W minus t
this is of Dimension 2D
and and let's take a
WT 0.2 I guess with this we we say that
this is the anchovies power of WT and
this means that with this notation X
tilde times WT
0.2 this is
x minus x times W plus t
2 W minus t so 2 and you can verify this
is really the same as the this is just
what the model computes
right this is the model output
on the data points
so I just want to use this so that so
that you have the Matrix notation and
now you can compute what's the
derivative
uh like of T was w dot T right this is
the gradient because we are doing
gradient flow so this is equals to the
gradient of L
item key and what's the gradient of L
item T this is gradient
of this loss function and now can be
written as
against the loss function
of WT now can be written as
x to the
WT 0.2 minus y back to Norm Square
that's because I vectorized everything
so
it's called replaced here
and then I take the gradient taking a
gradient you can use the chain rule so
uh if you believe me that I got a
correction rules this is actually the
transpose
RT
entry wise times WT
where RT
is equals to X tilde
times wto2
minus y back is the residual vector
so if you are familiar with linear
regression you will realize that this
is kind of like
this is what you got from the it is so
this is the if if it was linear
regression
if it is linear regression then this
time will be upgraded
and now it's not linear regression
because you have the quadratic
parameters model that's why you also
have to do chain rule to look at the
derivative of the quadratic of WT that's
why this is this is because
it's quadratic
anyway so you know if this is just one
way to think about why this is true but
the the formal verification would be
just that you look at little chain rules
app by everything
oh sorry sorry there's a
there should be a I think there's a two
here
wait
uh let me see
I think I wanted to make a two
so that means I think my loss function
should have a half
so where is my last function
okay the loss function
is so hard
I guess I also Define a lot of
functioning somewhere else before
here
right that sounds good
let me
like like my brain just automatically
remove all the constant
[Applause]
so it's very hard for me to deal with
this I can
Okay cool so
um
all right okay so now
how do we kind of like we we said that
we want to have some environments for
this in some sense right we're going to
somehow solve this differential equation
but you cannot really solve it exactly
this is
I I'm not an expert on solving
differential equations but I think this
is beyond the
the scope of like like this is something
you cannot really have
have uh have a close form solution
but the interesting way you can do you
can you can you can get something
without solving it exactly
so we claim that
so actually this is a paper they just
say the claim is easy to verify this
um you can claim that
WT satisfies the following
since like this times exponential minus
two x cubed transpose
key
all right
yes
okay why this is the case so first of
all this is not a solution this is not
like a it depending on what you mean by
Solutions this is not necessarily my
definition or closed person solution
because RIS still is a function of w
right so
but it's going to be something you very
useful
for us and why and why this is true
um it's actually relatively simple but
so here is the reason
so this is because
uh what you can do suppose you have a
suppose you have a
like a differential equation something
like U dot T is equals to VT times u t
so I'm trying to abstract fight a little
bit so that I can um I can give a clean
analysis so you can see that this is a
good abstraction of what we had
before because before on the left hand
side you have the derivative of w and on
the right hand side you have something
times W itself so this will be U this
will be V this will be U and this is U
dot T right that's my abstraction
oh and then suppose you have such a
thing that you can always do the
following you can say that U dot t
not over u g is equals to VT
right that's always true and then the
left hand side this is a part of the
magical thing in many cases like this is
log of
derivative of the log of u t
spect
I think probably I've seen this in other
contexts like policy ingredients in
other cases depending on whether you
know on your clothes but anyway so and
then
you can integrate both sides
so you can say if you integrate
you get a log of U T minus log of u0
is equals to the integration of the
right hand side
and have this
and now you remove the log you get the
exponential so u g
over u0
is exponential times integration of this
and now uh if you map U
to W and
V to this I guess U2 uh
according of w and V to be a
a coordinate of this x transpose r
t i then you can apply this and you get
the the desired result and by the way I
think I need to make a remark here that
this is entry wise
application of exponential
so this is a vector this is another
Matrix so a matrix system of vector this
becomes a vector and you take anti-wise
exponential and you take the antivirus
product with w0
okay any questions so far
so now let's see why this is useful it's
a little bit magical in my opinion I
don't have a
[Music]
um
you know conceptual I think this is fun
but I think the the the the proof on a
proof level is somehow there's a little
kind of like
either you can call it coincidence on
Magic so so there turns out that this is
all you need to to verify this is a good
solution uh this is the minimizer of the
on of the solution so first of all first
of all we turn this into something about
stata right so now we have a craft
position for w and let's turn it into
something about stata so recall that so
and also we simplify this a little bit
we call it w
plus 0 is Alpha o1 vector W minus 0 is
Alpha times over one vector so that
means that W 0 is also all one Alpha
times all Vector this this is in 2D
dimension because W is a concatenation
of W plus and W minus
so that's why this saying w0 is
basically not important you just have
Alpha
so on the Theta t
so the stata at time t
is W plus t
power 2 minus W minus t to the power 2
and this will be
uh
okay let's use this formula let's use
this formula let's call this one
using one
so the w0 doesn't matter right only
thing it contributes Alpha so we get
Alpha Square
and
so and
um
I guess I'm not sure let's see so
maybe I'll just do this small
preparation here so X tilde transpose is
X transpose minus X transpose
so that's why exponential
minus 2x to the transpose
some vector v
we we will be this uh integral
so this will be a vector
like
um
so let's say it's supposed to take this
to the power of 2 then we'll this will
be exponential minus 2
X
transpose B because this part is the
from the first part and the exponential
minus two
uh minus
times 2x transpose B
and then to the power 2.
okay so and then this and this power 2
will become 4 because it's exponential
so we got better so
four minus 4X transpose B exponential
for X transpose
so this small derivation is trying to
simple to deal with this so you know
that
this thing to the power 2 will be
something like this
and and then the first part corresponds
to
the first part corresponds to W plus and
second particle W minus so that's why
you got to
um
something like here
W plus Square will be
uh
exponential minus 4
X transpose
and minus
exponential
for x transposes
I guess what I I'm doing here is just
trying to make make you believe that
this derivation is true but it should be
it should be trivial derivation there is
nothing like difficult
so and
okay so this is the characterization of
theta and and you can see that this is
[Music]
um
um this exponential of this minus x
minus of the same thing you can write
this more succinctly as
the sign the Cinch
for
X transpose
this is just about a definition of the
Cinch I think cinch is something like
exponential t plus x minus minus t over
2 something like that
so okay so basically we have a
calculation of theta
and
uh
right and then you know that the Fatal
Alpha
right is equal to Theta Alpha as if at
Infinity
right so he so this is equals to 2 Alpha
Square
minus four x transpose
zero to Infinity RS DS
foreign
the final count Point satisfied maybe
let's call this equation two and we also
know that X said Alpha is equals to Y
because we assume or we can prove I
guess we discussed this I think we can
prove that
um you convert to a feasible solution
um so and I'm claiming that one two
so two and three these two things turned
out to be
to the optimality condition
of the of the program
of the of the the program
that's called one so one is this
argument thing okay I guess it's far far
away so here
let's call this program program one
right so you want to say that say the
alpha is the minimizer of this program
one and it turns out that set it Alpha
satisfies these two equations
two and three and these two equations
are the optimality condition of that
optimization program one so and and that
optimization problem only has one
solution because it's convex
so so so that's why this second Alpha is
the solution
that's the that's the plan for next
right sounds good so so by automatic
condition I really mean okay kkt
conclusion
um so I'm not sure whether
all of you are familiar with the kkt
condition so I guess there are two ways
to think about this
this is just a small
uh thing about background about kkt
conversation
so these are optimality conditions
for constraints optimization problems
to be honest I never really remember
exactly what the calculator generation
in many cases so what I well I'm gonna
show you is that one way to think about
it so
um which is probably not exactly
the same as what you can read from the
from the book but it's going to be very
similar so suppose you have this kind of
things right optimization program like
this and Q Theta is a convex thing
and so so first of all the the quantity
condition is the following
so it says that Q Theta
is to be equal to X transpose V for some
V
um in dimension I think this Dimension
is n
and the next data needs to be equal to Y
so this is the kkt condition for this
kind of program
and you know one last thing you can do
is you can just look up a book and and
like just a invoke a theorem from a book
saying which says that this is the
optimality condition
um the way I think about it is the
following if you're interested in it so
the way I remember this is that
I remember this
all right derived this every time if I
need it uh
as follows
so I think that the Insight is that
optimality
at least means that there's no first
order update there is no first order
local Improvement
so if you perturb your solution
you shouldn't have a first order
Improvement locally if a portable
solution locally a little bit but if
that has no small amount you shouldn't
get get
a a noun to your first other Improvement
so
so but you also have to satisfy the
constraints so you also like a known for
the
local Improvement satisfying the
constraint
since we're not constant act also up to
first order
because you may not be able to
so what does this mean in this case it
means that suppose we consider
perturbation the outside
right this is a perturbation
so how do you satisfy the constraints to
satisfy the constraint you have to say
that the perturbation needs to be in the
orthogonal to the ghost line
of x
because if it's not an integral spell
facts you you perturb it you may change
the you may change the X Theta and then
you you change the you don't satisfy
constraint anymore so this is the way to
satisfy Constitution so that you you
actually so that X layer Theta is zero
so that's how you make the constraint
work and now let's look at say the plus
they'll say the local perturbation
and so this still satisfy the
constituent and let's see what's the
value
so so
so let's see what's the value of Q so Q
said A Plus Delta Theta
this is equals to
up to first order Q signal
plus Delta Vector times
hi professor
we cannot hear you
maybe let's try this can you hear me now
thanks for letting me know
yes
um is the audio good or not is it okay
okay so I'm using the my laptops on
microphone so maybe let me turn it in
some way so that
yeah thanks for letting me know so maybe
I'll rewind a little bit back I don't
know how far how long time you have lost
me
um
so so I guess uh maybe I'll just briefly
go through the steps that
we have discussed that so so
I guess I was saying that um if you have
the perturbation
on
you always satisfy the constraint right
the preservation is the lowest value of
x is also going to the real span of X
then you always satisfy the constant and
we want to understand
we want to figure out in under what
condition this preservation will never
improve your function will make the
function bigger because if it makes the
function bigger it means that this point
is not optimal so so that's why you look
at a Taylor expansion of the of this
queue and you found out that the first
other changes is this term and you want
this term to be always
you know negative non-positive because
if it's positive then it violates the
optimality Assumption so so so so it's a
necessary condition is that this term is
always non-positive but this term you
know it's very easy to make the sign
flip because you can use the flip the
allocator
um by whatever you want so that
basically means that for every denotator
in this goes orthogonal space of low
span of X this term has to be just
literally zero because if it's not zero
you can flip the illustrator to make it
positive
so that's why we are saying that here
for every data center of x this term is
zero and that really just means that
this Vector so because
every data set in the rows in this
subject is also equal to this Vector
that means that this Vector is in a
complementary
Subspace
of the subscript so that's why this
Vector Q Theta needs to be in the real
span
of x
so that for every Vector Dela Theta or
thousands the real slang the inner
product is zero so so that's why this is
this it can be written as X transpose
times U
because X transpose if you don't call it
the low spine X transpose mu X transpose
I think this is that's called v x
transpose B is the uh is the
representation of a vector in a row span
of x
so that's why this is the
that's how we develop the package
information right the package
information was that you have to be in
the lowest one the gradient of Trio as
Theta has to be the low smile of X and
also has to be a feasible solution
Okay cool so this is some segregation
about kkt conditions if you not familiar
with it then the only important thing is
that this is the calculation of the
optimal solution uh I say that and and
we can now it's just a pattern matching
right so
so this
corresponds to this right obviously and
this one
really just corresponds to equation two
because
equation two okay that's what I'm going
to claim okay it's not to you yet but
let's see that so
um
so kkt tells you that the gradient of Q
Theta needs to be something like X
transpose V and the the environment
or the differential equation tells us
that let me just copy paste it just let
me just rewrite it so Theta Alpha is
equals to
Alpha Square
Sun
all right so first of all let's rewrite
this as
to simplify this and we write this as
times V
times
maybe B Prime let's see because the V
what we it doesn't matter and then
and then you can
uh
I guess let's also look work on the Q
set of scene the data Q say that you can
compute this
in some sense you know when you derive
the queue you you we are verifying it
but actually what you have what you have
to do is to reverse anything to do this
in another Direction but but if you just
verify that suppose you have given a q
if you're just going to prove it you can
find the derivative of the queue will be
just Arc
cinch
one over two of a square
times Theta
this is the derivative of Q it makes
sense because the Q is the sum of
some function outside the I and the
derivative Q is a if each answer is the
same function of theta I
and and so so then you can see that this
if you plug in the set Alpha here
to this thing so Arc since
file score so the alpha this is equals
to
just 4X transpose V Prime
right so that's why
so so basically that's why gradient Q
Theta Alpha
is equals to minus four x transpose e
Prime
and and this satisfies the 10
interpolation the four doesn't matter
because the v v can be any vector
right so so that's why Q Alpha satisfy
the paper stories
like that so so so is the global mean
physical
I guess you know the last step you know
satisfying hey the condition means
Global mean uh this requires the
convection of this program the
constraint is linear is convex the the
objective
um you can verify still a social complex
it's it's something between our one
normal complex
foreign
so if there's no questions I'm going to
move on to the next thing which is about
classification problem
yeah as many of you are saying like
there's proof Steve like this proof
I don't know I don't have um
you know the the plan sounds very
intuitive right so how do you prove
something is the minimizer for com
optimization problem you have to verify
it satisfies the cable companies I guess
that's probably the more or less the
only way to do it if you want to show
something is the optimizer of some
optimization program
but but it's kind of the magical why it
just happens to satisfy the kkg
so uh of course there's something that
we can choose right we can choose the
queue to make it satisfy the
communication that's something you can
choose but the magical thing is that
other things all match up like the more
of the ACT transpose time something all
of those things are messed up and also
you can somewhat in some sense you can
always work with each coordinate
independently in this special case so
that's also something that
maybe a little special to this uh to
this special model that we considering
all right okay so now let's move on
classification problem and and we are
looking at separable data
um as we always do for classification
problem
and
and here we are going to only discuss by
results and uh which says that
um if you do green it is that it
converters to a Max Market solution
and this is actually
it doesn't require any
doesn't
require
any differentiation like it works for
any tradition
like uh so the only thing you need is
really decent and some loss function
which I will Define and no
regularization you just compute Green
Design on the loss function you run for
a long time you're going to convert some
maximization source
so
um so I will have again start with the
setup
so now we have a data set x i y i
promise to n
and x i
are in Rd
and y i
is a binary label plus one minus one
all right
okay so
um
[Music]
been to a restaurant
because it breaks down
okay yeah so the question is about the
previous thing and the question is about
if you don't use W Square you use W to
the K and this is a very good question
actually this is exactly what the paper
studies in the in a more technical part
so
um and the short answer is that
everything can still go through and the
but the eventual Q would be different so
the form of your queue would be
something not l102 I think it's
something like I'll it depends on the
power
so I think if the power is P I don't
exactly remember but I think it's
something like a 2 over P Norm when
Alpha is close to zero but Alpha is
going to Infinity I think
everything's still the same
like the ntk regime is now sensitive to
this so so okay and the technically why
did everything go through I think the
reason why everything goes through is
that
roughly speaking
you are only playing with this this
single dimensional function in some
sense right so so so it won't be sent
anymore probably there will be some
constant some other function
um and but still this x transpose
something is still there I think it's
now changed uh and
So eventually you just have to engineer
different queue to make everything work
and the queue is still kind of call only
depends on the coordinates right you do
something on each corner and you take
the sum the queue still has that support
so that's why it's still someone doable
Okay cool so
going back to the classification problem
so this is our setup and here we are
only going to do the linear model
even though some of this Theory still
works for nonlinear model with roughly
similar technique and similar conclusion
um and here we're going to have a loss
function so the loss function
will be
I'll hat w
is the the
let's say we do the cross entropy laws
the the logistic loss
across entry laws
times h w x defined
and where this lost is this logistic
loss which is log
of one class exponential
density
Okay cool so
um
and the first thing is that to to kind
of like there's some intuition so first
of all we have multiple
Global mean
if a separable data
so this is a premises for any implicit
requisition Factor if you don't have one
Global mean then and you can convert the
global I mean there's no impressive
organization class
this is just because you can
um
you can always have like a infinite
number of like separators pretty much
unless in a very extreme case you just
happen to get stuck at the exactly so so
for example let's I think it's probably
easy to draw something
so suppose you have some data points
like this
and
you have so many different possible
separators
as long as you have one you perturb a
little but it's still a separate so so
they are so there is this the infinite
my name w
such that
W transpose x i y i
is bigger than 0 for every r
so you have so many separators and for
every w
for maybe let's say for infant number of
w bar such that where W bar is in it
the real bar is unit vector
this statement doesn't really depend on
the log so you can always scale it so
for every W bar for any W bar such that
this
you can scale it so if you look at our
hat Alpha w
bar
so we'll go to zero as
Alpha goes to Infinity so any scaling of
this unit separator
if you scale it extremely
then you are gonna get uh the loss goes
to zero so basically you have so many
directions in it so you can go to
Infinity in different directions and
still converts to uh uh zero loss so
basically in some sense if you are a
little sloppy about so all of the this
infinity times W bar
are Global minimum
of this loss function just because the
loss function goes to zero at Infinity
the loss function maybe I should also
draw this the loss function looks like
this
this is the layer of T when T goes to
Infinity you get close to zero
close to zero loss and and and what's
inside what what's t t is y times double
transpose x i and this thing will go to
efficiency as you scale the norm of the
of the classifier
so so you have so many directions that
you can you can find uh there are so
many Global minimums the question is
which
which direction
can you find
by agreeing distance right if you don't
use any if you don't if you just invoke
a theorem about optimization you know
that green Nissan will find a solution
with every close to zero with loss close
to zero but you don't know which
direction it is you still have a bunch
of flexibilities a few many directions
can
um if you go to Infinity in my
directions you can get the loss to uh
back here
so that's the question that we're
actually going to address
so
um and we're going to say that this
actually converges the max smarter
solution
so let's define
so the answer is Max modern solution
production
so I guess let's define maybe first the
marginalized
the the margin and the normalized margin
so so I guess we have defined the margin
in this class many case whereas in many
cases
the margin is the minimum
this
uh and we also assume okay so assume we
always assume
assume uh linearly separable
see this this calculation is only
defined for cases where it's linearly
separable and a normalized margin
is defined to be you normalize this by
the norm of w
because otherwise you can make the
Norm arbitrary repeat
carburetor is small
Okay so
so max Martin Solutions
is defined to be the
for all w
which one give you the maximum
normalized margin
um and let's
W store be the
maximizer
this is the direction of the max margin
solution and with uninor because
if you only look at this objective
or it doesn't depend on the scale
because the scale is already normalized
so
um so we Define them that will start
with a maximizer recently notes okay so
basically we're going to prove that if
you do win descent you're going to go to
Infinity but it already will go to
Infinity but only a lot of direction of
w star
that's the zero
so green and Flow
okay
here you are talking we're talking about
gradient flow just because you know it's
convenient as we discussed so convert
this to
uh the direction
of Max Martin Solutions
in the sense that
I think we don't really exactly say that
convergence interaction we only say the
convergence in the
in the sense of like the value of the
margin
uh I think really you want to do the
exact convergence interaction is it
requires a little more work
so what we say is that the margin of
your iterate will convert to the maximum
possible margin gamma bar
um
right so
as T goes to Infinity
so and WT is the wtd
is the eteric attack key
foreign
this is working
um this intrusion contains while this is
working and how do we prove it in some
kind of a mixture of both of these two
and then in the next lecture I guess I
would improve the the thing more
reversive
so why this is going why this is working
so the intuition is that
so okay so I have a few steps here so
once step one this loss function I all
had
WT
is going to zero
by standard
optimization argument
which
which is not covered by this course so
but I think you can quickly leave it if
you optimization is working your
if your optimization is working then
your um a loss should go to zero
and
second
so this is
object finish one and observation two
um
I guess the laws
this loss function
which we Define to the logistic loss
right
something like this
loss function is actually
uh close to exponential
for
large C
right this is just because you do total
expansion right log of 1 plus X is
approximately X that's where you can get
rid of the log and one
and this is actually an interesting
thing right so you call it logistic loss
but actually it's close to exponential
loss so like
so so like uh so Logistics a lot so
logistic loss is close to exponential
loss
so so so so then so in most of the proof
actually we are only going to do the
logistics I think I think the proof
actually I'm just going sorry I'm going
to the exponential loss so in the proof
I'm going to just assume it's
exponential
um even though you can still these small
differences can be
um dealt with relatively easily
and the third observation is that
because one because of one
the WT
has to go to the norm has to go to
Infinity
and and the reason is that if you just
don't go to Infinity you never make the
loss close to zero now right this is
just because
if WT is bounded
however let's say it's mined by B
suppose it's always bounded then
you can always bounce this y i times W
transpose x i by something like
maybe B times the norm of x i you have
some bonds
so this is bounded
and then your loss L height WT
this is you know
bonded by
exponential minus E times x i
something like this
and this is my below by zero and this
contradictory is one
right so if you if your Norm is always
belonging then your loss is pointed
below by some number the number is you
know very close to zero but it still
responded by some number which
contradicts with the convergence to zero
so
so now it comes to the the most
important thing so with a lot of this
preparation so we know that the norm
goes to infinity and then suppose let's
say let's only look at the final case
the later regime where WT
is very big so suppose WT
to Norm is really big that's called Q is
very big
so
then let's try to simplify the loss
function see what the loss function is
found so the loss function
I can't
so maybe let's let's remove the key just
for Simplicity let's just look at
suppose you want to look at some W such
that the W Norm is very big so the l h w
is the sum of
this logistic loss or exponential loss
we're not distinguishing for now
and this is
uh let's say this is roughly equals to
the exponential minus y
I times double transpose x i
and because the loss will be very close
to zero it's actually more informative
to look at the log space
um so if you took a log space of L hat w
then this is roughly equals to
the log
of sum
of exponential minus y i
times W transpose times F1
so this is a log sum exponential I'm not
sure whether it is we're about to some
of you so this is basically soft Max
um so so I'm gonna claim that this lots
of exponential is close to Max
of this
minus this
am I yes
so why this is the case let's do some
again abstract derivation
so if you have a log
okay I guess sorry I think I'm
probably I should have another status so
let's first another step
so this will lock some exponential but
also I can try to
I want to use the fact that YW has large
Norm right so let's
get a norm of WQ in front you get y i
tends W bar transpose x i
where W bar is equal to normalization of
w
okay so now I'm going to claim that this
is close to
Max minus q y i
double transpose XI i o
so why this is the case this is I guess
if those who are familiar with this you
know lock some exponential is kind of
like a soft Max
so if you look at log some
exponential of some
I said Q
times UI
I'm trying to kind of like
um abstract it by a little bit right so
you have a hue that is very large and UI
is something fixed I claim that this is
closed this is roughly
Q times the max of UI
i n
plus something like little of Q
something like that that doesn't depend
on keyword as much as qbox Infinity
so when the queue is very big then this
is really doing the Max and sometimes
this is kind of like when you do a
temperature in the soft max if you make
it big then
you soft Max becomes hard Max
so and and if you do the then this is
really in some kind of soft Max
and and this is you know if you want how
to improve this just say the sum of
exponential q u i
proper upper bound the upper bound is
that
it's a log of
replace each of these back by the
biggest one
exponential few times the max
UI
and this is only log on
plus Q
times the max of UI
and
so the login is small compared to Q
because Q will go to infinity and I need
something fixed in this abstraction and
on the other hand you just take one term
you just only keep the term you have the
max then you get Q next
UI or you jump all the other terms
there's no sum anymore log cancels with
exponential
to get this
so so basically
um
there's lots of exponential is close to
the max up to some
Factor log n but this Factor log n will
be small if Q goes to Infinity
and that that justifies this step
right so and once you have this done
this uh what's going on here right so
this is saying that you are
you are minimizing a lot you're
minimizing law so that's why you
minimize the log loss as well right so
so so so minimizing loss is kind of like
trying to maximize this and that means
you are maximizing the
so so you are trying to maximum minimize
this quantity
minimize the quantity Max minus q y i
will transpose x i
which means it's the same as maximizing
which means that so you are you are
you are minimizing but you're maximizing
the mean of Q
y i w transpose x y
right so it's so you just select this
time
right
minimizing the max of this is the same
as maximizing an email this is just
literally the same thing
like without any it's not like you're
switching in the max it's just a really
the Sun
you have the minus sign you maximize
something is the same as
the max of this is equals to
the minus the mean
q y double transpose XL
and then you can put this minus also the
minimize Okay so
so
um all right so basically you are
maximizing the margin that's uh that's
uh what is the same so if you do this
approximation
uh then you have maximized margin if Q
goes to infinite and next time we're
going to make this more formal uh with a
little bit with essentially the same
intuition but the truth you know would
be more clear it's not exactly like this
it's not like you're dealing with arrows
okay it's going to be a very clean proof
um
okay I think that's uh yeah that's all
for today thanks